whoa
that looks super gross
yo what's up internet we're gonna teach
you guys how to make cool pano pictures
what are panos well you've probably seen
them around they're panorama phone
camera glitches basically ones where
maybe there's like a baby that's
stretched out across the floor or
someone's face is appearing in five
parts of the image that's happening
because you're glitching out the
panorama feature of your phone this is
how it works your phone sees the image
before the world before it and it takes
pictures
reading it as you're moving the phone so
if you want to glitch it out you start
moving things against or with the way
that the phone is scanning the image how
do you gauge where the phone is reading
the images it's a little hard to tell
when you have to watch your preview
screen to get the hang of it but after a
few of them you'll find it no time this
is particularly important when trying to
do the scrunched face ones and the only
way to see that is just to gauge the
preview once again and you're panning up
they'll look down and you'll see that
little line starting to chop the center
of their face creating a glitched out
scrunchy face image so the real trick to
getting really funny looking panorama
images is when you're looking that
little preview window like it's super
tiny and it's showing you where the
image is scanning right in the middle
that window is where it's actually
updating the picture so right in the
middle that window when you're moving
your phone is where you want to be
gauging where you're going to be moving
things and shifting things to get them
distorted dude your phone is so broken
all right ready jake so put your arm out
the other direction
that way
i'm gonna hit go
and start
moving stop
boom
there we go
[Laughter]
done wait wait here what's the reverse
one we need a reverse one reverse
crunchy so you're gonna go
when i stand up you're gonna turn your
head up
ready so head down
[Music]
here let's do a short stack arms and
legs need to be in line with the camera
because you are you need to create
straight lines
dude
that looks so small you you need to cut
off before the knees though you're right
let's do it one time here ren i'm gonna
do a short stack of you all right while
holding the camera while holding the
camera all right
three two one go
get that on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
awesome dude
you're pretty short there except god see
seeing the leg bend is a little hard to
deal with yeah
you have to like go
turn yourself into a box can you make my
head this big as big as the whole room
i'll try all right from here rather than
cut off the line mid section you're
cutting it at the neck and moving the
head forwards to enlarge it come
straight to the camera
[Music]
so that's basically how to make a pano
picture if you guys make anything cool
and you want to share it make sure you
tweet them at us at corridor digital and
watch out for cops because they don't
like it when you do it to them so have
fun and uh good luck out there you're
only limited by your imagination
and your phone's memory space yes panos
you're only limited
by your imagination
you